the boss rides a wooden bicycle that
fits right in with his line of business
producing luxury mattresses from
all-natural materials power left my
fetus started his company over 20 years
ago the headquarters are in Athens but
production is in the north of Greece he
has to import coconut fiber and natural
rubber from Asia but the capital
controls keep him from paying his
supplier fortunately he has subsidiaries
abroad that can do it efully a new
mouseland happen to you subsidiaries
abroad help the parent company pay the
bill ship it Sally yeah we've worked
with our suppliers for quite a long time
it's a man they know full well that
they'll get their money yet become Vaden
to fmo fetus punctuality is just as
important in paying his suppliers as in
delivering the goods now his company's
authorized to transfer money abroad but
the procedure involves so much red tape
that it can take weeks they need the
specific kind voice they need the
authenticity of the specific invoice
they need the certification that we have
not requested this apply this payment
from another Bank we keep the whole
department of accounting in Treasury in
order to make payments for this for this
region
for smaller companies banking
restrictions and bills left unpaid can
add up to huge problems this fashion
boutique in athens old town is a family
business they produce a line of clothing
under their own label a trade fair is
coming up in France where they would
normally buy new fabric but now they
don't know how they can pay for it we
don't have the exact image and we don't
know if we will face any problems we
hope not but we don't know yet they're
lucky they decided to go mostly with
domestic materials early on a
long-standing partner is a cotton
processor outside Athens it's a
four-hour drive to farsala in the north
past cotton fields Greece is still the
European Union's largest supplier of
cotton even after most of his textile
factories have had to close in recent
years this is one of the last remaining
big producers the entire facility costs
some 20 million euros most of its
high-quality yarn is sold abroad to
companies like Benetton and Zara but
this summer with capital controls
hobbling the economy every step of the
way the company's hardly been able to
find trucks to haul it the summer break
gave them a little breathing space
selected was lucky that capital controls
came in a period that the most companies
in Europe closing down for vacation it
was July and August and this was for us
indirectly a big support if something
like that happens in may or april the
problem would be bigger so far the
company hasn't had to scale back
production but if the capital controls
are kept in force it might it has a
workforce of 350 and wants to hold on to
them one thing it's hundred percent sure
Greece has to invest in production we
have to produce values added values in
order to be independent and not always
ask for credits to survive made in
Greece many people here say that's what
the country has to build on but before
companies can grow they have to survive